jean michel bayle est le président des
radicaux de gauche à l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir métro soir merci d'être
avec nous après les questions
d'actualité nombreuses que je vais vous
poser on vous interrogera on vous
entendra sur votre positionnement
politique où vous situez-vous exactement
jean michel bayle est vous qui avoué
être séduit aujourd'hui par jean louis
borloo on en parlera un peu plus tard
dans cette émission puisque patrick
roger du monde et puis perrine tarneaud
2 public sénat nous rejoindront donc
nous commençons par les polémiques bien
sûr sur les voyages de michèle alliot
marie et françois fillon en tunisie en
égypte désormais donc un ministre devra
demander l'autorisation avant dans les
points à vendre avant d'aller passer ses
vacances à l'étranger est ce que c'est
une bonne réponse qu'ils viennent en
midi pyrénées au delà de ça je pense que
cette affaire a quand même ses affaires
en quand même une fois de plus altéré
l'image des politiques donc il est temps
de fixer les règles du jeu et qu'elle
soit respectée il faut qu'elle soit
claire et je pense que ça tombe
finalement bien fraîche dire à chaque
chose malheur est bon avec la commission
sauvé qui a travaillé sur les conflits
d'intérêts d'ailleurs j'ai été invité en
tant que président du prg à m'exprimer
devant tels des propositions sont en
passe d'être fait
il faut dire clairement ce qui est
permis ou pas autrement l'opinion
publique a vraiment une capacité facile
l'opinion médiatique aussi dix ans le
entamé l'air du tous pourris c'est très
dangereux pour la démocratie
la france est un des pays qui est
peut-être un peu à la traîne quant à des
règles très strictes par rapport à
grande bretagne par rapport aux etats
unis quand obama est venu en visite
officielle à paris là dormi à
l'ambassade des états unis
c'est pas nos traditions d'un accablante
par françois fillon michèle alliot-marie
disons que tout cela est regrettable et
qu'il faut maintenant que les règles du
jeu soient claires et qu'elles soient
respectées par tous et qu'il n'y aura
pas d'exception donc pas un accablement
donc plutôt de la compréhension de
d'autre part de la monf études même
peut-être fort fillon a salué par
exemple la retenue j'ai deux sénateurs
jean-pierre chevènement et puis à robert
badinter vous êtes plutôt sur cette
ligne là je pense qu'ils font il ya eu
elle est plutôt d'ordre politique de la
part de michèle alliot-marie d'être allé
en tunisie alors que la révolution avait
commencé alors qu'elle est mini affaires
étrangères bon elle a prétendu qu'elle
avait été mal informée par ses
collaborateurs restent en la regardant
le futur il veut utiliser de rémission
arrêtons demander l'émission tout le
monde à tout bout de champ ça ne tient
pas debout et la démocratie et la
république ne peuvent pas vivre comme ça
et concernant françois fillon dernier
vaut aujourd'hui qu'il est affaibli
néanmoins par cette polémique
on ne ressort jamais un stack de
polémiques comme celle là on ne ressort
jamais un taquin l'opinion publique est
en souffrance à ce moment deux par la
crise économique et les difficultés des
français considèrent que ce que vous
avez fait n'est pas tout à fait
convenable mais ce n'est pas une raison
pour en rajouter
regardons le futur d'accord à bien le
futur c'est en quelques jours
dans quelques heures même nicolas
sarkozy sur tf1 jeudi soir
est ce que vous attendez de sa part des
engagements nouveaux efforts tenue pour
une république irréprochable
la république irréprochable serait
d'abord dans le comportement europe
irréprochable du prennent la république
qu'il respecte la constitution qu'il
respecte la séparation des pouvoirs
qu'il respecte la séparation de
l'exécutif et du législatif et qu' il
n'est pas toujours cette volonté d'être
l'omniprésident qui se mêlent de tout
qui s'occupe de tout et qui voudraient
tout régler sans y arriver naturellement
parce que c'est tout à fait impossible
donc d'abord un problème de forme
ensuite un point de fort qui nous parle
des problèmes qui concernent aujourd'hui
les les français que ce soit la
situation de l'emploi que ce soit les
services publics que ce soit les
fonctionnaires je pense en particulier
aux seniors seize mille postes supprimés
après onze mille cinq cents l'an dernier
et 17000 annoncé l'année prochaine on va
fermer des écoles rurales
on va regrouper des classes on ne peut
pas continuer comme ça c'est cela que
j'attends de la du prêt puis quand vous
avez fait allusion bien sûr aux
critiques du chef de l'état sur la
justice selon où elles sont infondées
est-ce qu'elles affaiblissent
l'institution judiciaire l'article 64 de
la constitution dit que le président de
la république est le garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
je pense que le premier public devrait
méditer cette phrase de la constitution
et apports et limites
après l'avoir méditer qu'ils appliquent
ils ne l'appliquent pas s'il est le
garant de leur indépendance il ne peut
pas les montrer du doigt et les
condamner à tout bout de champ moi je ne
dis pas que la justice est parfaite je
ne dis pas que l'inamovibilité des jeux
l'irresponsabilité des jeux ne sont pas
des choses dont on devrait discuter mais
je dis que tant que le fonctionnement
est celui là il faut respecter la
justice qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles dans un monde de
plus en plus violents quand vous obtenez
la fronde des gens l'aiment et istres
avec des affaires de plus en plus
difficiles à traiter est aussi frappé
par la part la réduction de nombre de
magistrats
donc je les comprends vous les jeunes et
je n'ai rien n'est vrai comprenez vous
les sujets les gammes à vous demander de
soutenir un mouvement corporatiste
c'est pas de ma responsabilité alors
vous n'allez pas empêché tout comme moi
je les ai vus et les grandes valeurs
je n'ai pas l'habitude à la langue de
bois je suis comme toi mais je comme
branchement est grande je le soutiens
comment et donc je ne sous traite donc
voilà c'est clair c'est clair je le
soutiens pourquoi quant à dix tribunaux
près la plupart des tribunaux sont en
rébellion
en tout cas contestation forte le
cantonais responsables politiques
on ne peut pas ne pas s'interroger et ne
pas soutenir c'est une lame de fond ne
sais pas la petite revendications
corporatistes d'humains d'accord
d'accord on revient aux grandes valeurs
l'indépendance de la justice et le
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs et
respecter la constitution
ces neurones de près la république une
république n'est pas irréprochable vous
nous dites que ce soit c'est d'abord la
faute de nicolas sarkozy je vous dis que
le prêt à la république doit donner
l'exemple et je répète que nicolas
sarkozy ne donne pas toujours l'exemple
de la sérénité et de la bonne méthode à
mécénat fraîche et les styles de forme
et de fond mais la forme est très
importante
comme vous voyez que nicolas sarkozy est
tombée à 30%
dans l'est dans les sondages donc deux
français sur trois qui le désapprouvent
et avait quelque chose de nouveau une
sorte d'inimitié encore de bonnes
répliques on ne trouvait pas pour
mitterrand ou pour chirac qui ont eu
aussi la paix leurs pertes leurs
périodes difficiles c'est parce que le
style de présidence énerve les français
qui sont dans une période de difficultés
ionel on en change jamais vous le savez
en quand on la reçoit
quand on met 30 ans comme il l'a fait et
comme il le revendique à se former par
la république il faut peut-être quand on
y est arrivé considéré qu'on doit se
courait dans le costume il ne l'a pas
fait et il a eu tort et ils en payent
les conséquences
et puis il ya le faut mais le fossé
toute la politique menée par la majorité
et par an par la droite française à
laquelle nous sommes en désaccord
vainqueur de cela nous aurons l'occasion
de reparler du salaire bien sûr bien sûr
je reviens d'un mot d'ailleurs sur les
polémiques concernant les séjours et les
voyages dans les pays arabes la tunisie
l'egypte est ce que ces polémiques
affaiblissent aujourd'hui la diplomatie
française bien naturellement quand les
ces pays qui sont en lutte quasi
révolutionnaire pour la liberté pour la
démocratie
et naturellement il se référant cela à
la france dont on sait quel est le grand
pays des libertés qu'elle a donné
l'exemple au monde entier de par sa
propre révolution
candy voit le comportement des
gouverneurs soit dit en passant cas mais
nous avions les trois principaux
responsables du gouvernement dans
l'étranger pendant cette période le prêt
la république au maroc le premier
ministre en egypte et l'ami affaires
étrangères en tunisie peut être quelques
autres je ne suis pas allé regarder
c'est pas quand mais notre très bonne
méthode non plus pour pour mener les
affaires de l'état mais revenons aux
peuples arabes ce qui s'est passé là-bas
ce vent de liberté qui souffle ce vent
de démocratie
cette volonté ils ont payé de leur vie
il faut quand même
non seulement le respecter mais crée les
conditions sans interventionnisme ne
revenant pas encore dialyse pour que
tout cela aboutisse
or lorsqu'il voit le comportement des
responsables je ne crois pas que ce soit
le meilleur exemple donc il faut changer
les comportements
je reviens il faut fixer des amis je
vais pas changer de ministres est pas
changé la ministre c'est pas ça
par un beau temps de s'exprimer non mais
mais créer les conditions pour que nos
diplomates soit à l'écouté ça n'a
peut-être pas été toujours le cas non
plus et que ce formidable élan qui est
né en tunisie et en egypte sont
transformés par démocratie par la
création de démocratie irréprochable et
que cela fasse tache d'huile avec
bonheur dans l'ensemble de la zone
c'est pas chose facile il ya deux ans un
grain vous avez des gares des
intégristes islamistes
il y a les armes et qui ont l'habitude
quand même de diriger
il n'y a pas que des démocrates dans ces
pays mais je vois quand même que la
jeunesse et l'ensemble du peuple c'est
ce qui fera pas des jipes tu sais qu'ils
sont tous sur la place il ya les laïcs
il ya les religieux il ya les jeunes il
ya les vieux il ya tout le monde donc ça
c'est un fantastique appel d'air bien
sûr qu'il faut être qu'ils qu'il faut
être vigilant regardez ce qui s'est
passé en iran l'iran n'était pas une
démocratie étant du jeu en fait non je
ne vais pas le parallèle mais je dis
qu'il faut se souvenir de ces choses là
parce que c'est comme un exemple
déplorable car l'iran joue un rôle très
néfaste en tout sept secondes
alors jean michel baylet qu'on va parler
de votre positionnement politique mais
avant ça j'aimerais savoir comment vous
recevez le signe d'un sinclair donc un
dans le sens retrait net d'une
candidature deson de son époux dsk aux
primaires socialistes je pense que ça
n'aide pas une déclaration irréfléchie
et tout au contraire qu'ils ont à mon
avis travailler ensemble et que c'est un
véritable signe qui est envoyé à la
classe politique française et à
l'opinion publique
le signe comme quoi je franchi un pas
supplémentaire je ne suis pas encore
tout à fait candidat
en tout cas je ne peux pas le dire moi
même puisque je suis tenu par la réserve
mais regardez anne sinclair a été à ses
côtés dans tous les moments et souvent
s'est exprimé dans des moments
importants de la vie de dominique
strauss kahn
je pense que c'est un signe fort qui
demande bien sûr être confirmée mais on
ne peut pas le traiter comme une simple
déclaration plus ou moins réfléchie de
madame strauss kahn n'est qu'avec j'ai
envie de savoir ce que vous en pensez
sur le fond est ce que ça vous réjouit
cette perspective du retour de dsk
dominique strauss kahn est le favori des
sondages
oui et de vous langue ça ne peut que me
réjouir et vous de voir le champion
revenir parce que ma volonté de n'en
parleront peut-être tout à l'heure c'est
l'alternance
voilà et c'est ce que souhaitent les
radicaux
dominique strauss kahn est un socialiste
modéré vous maintenant des prêtres clair
vous voulez vraiment l'alternance droite
gauche nous voulons l'alternance
retrouver aujourd'hui d'accord et
firminy strauss kahn me semble
aujourd'hui de ce que disent les
sondages meilleur candidat
quant à son positionnement idéologique
il ne peut que réjouir les radicaux
d'accord donc si ce retour est confirmé
il faudra quand même attendre avec
quelques mois cela vous pourrez vous
ramener du côté du parti socialiste jean
michel baylet
ça c'est un autre débat non c'est ce
qu'ils sont non c'est un autre débat
parce que strauss kahn pour l'instant
n'est pas dans l'appareil socialiste
n'est pas à la direction du parti
socialiste
nous avons des difficultés aujourd'hui
avec le parti socialiste pour passer des
accords électoraux pour les sénatoriales
pour l'organisation des primaires voire
une partie si prépare ainsi pour
parcourir à notre grand regret n'oubliez
pas que les radicaux sont les premiers à
avoir demandé les primaires en 2016 lors
de notre université d'été en arles dont
nous le demande nous et nous ne sommes
pas c'est qu'il ya quand même moins de
faux et le point deux fois c'est
qu'elles sont organisées pour l'instant
en dépit du bon sens et dans la plus
grande opacité
mais nous continuons à considérer qu'il
faut créer les conditions pour limiter
le nombre de candidatures à gauche parce
que c'est dans l'unité que la victoire
et c'est dans la désunion coryse
retrouver madame le pen sur votre coeur
balance j'ai envie de vous demander jean
michel bayle est entre jean louis borloo
je lisais tout à l'heure ils vous séduit
vous avez envie d'un front républicain
avec tous les radicaux
je laisse que votre coeur balance entre
borloo entre strauss kahn
je vais me répéter à nous voulons
l'alternance c'est l'hiver nous voulons
qu'il y ait un autre près la république
que nicolas sarkozy qui les radicaux
sont de gauche donc nos familles
naturelles c'est la gauche ça c'est
clair aussi à partir de là nous sommes
des républicains laïcs tolérant
respectueux nous pouvons discuter avec
qui nous souhaitons pourquoi je ne
discuterai paraît bon lot d'abord qui
préside l'augmenter président du brésil
autre parti radical autres partir il est
sorti du gouvernement
il prétend nous verrons qu'ils vont
aussi sortir de l'ump
sacré quand même des bois dé proximité
on peut regarder
mais pour ces choses ou pas si josi s'il
choisit nicolas sarkozy nous ne serons
pas dans l'ensemble les choses sont
claires
mais quand même nous pouvons échanger
sur certaines de sujets avec quelqu'un
qui vient de sortir plus tôt et fracas
des gouvernements et qui est qui et qui
dit qui travaille à la sortie de
lui-même de la sortie de l'ump tient son
pouvoir et son prix totalement je suis
totalement oui parce que pas de vos
militants
les français voulaient nous présenter la
vie politique française de manière
totalement manichéenne comme une sorte
de guerre chimique et biologique fait
vous ne je veux l'alternance sûr mais
parce que ça c'est le fonctionnement
normal de la démocratie mais ensuite
pendant pendant les périodes autre que
la paire électorale on peut en discuter
les uns et les autres
pourquoi ça qu'avec n'y avait pas que du
bon endroit texte du bras gauche on le
sait que ça se saurait depuis longtemps
notamment c'est donc de réunir toute la
famille radicale alors on va voir
comment ça se passe déjà au sénat cette
famille était réunie d'une certaine
manière au sein d'un groupe aux contours
qui peuvent paraître quand même
insaisissable dès qu'on sort de la norme
absolue du bi polaire pour leurs
agissements
insaisissable et paradoxaux regardons ce
sujet des fabrice canet avant
d'accueillir notre confrère du monde
patrick roger avec qui les radicaux de
gauche
remue-méninges assuré au sénat difficile
de connaître à l'avancé leurs positions
sur les textes bien sûr officiellement
ils sont dans l'opposition mais les
profils des onze membres du groupe sont
très divers alors comme beaucoup de ses
collègues
le sénateur socialiste thierry repentin
s'y perd un peu comme la fonction qu'il
est homogène
oh moi je bougeais nuit mais dans le
respect de certaines différences
le total à nos gauchistes voilà je
dirais qu'il ya des vrais 109,5 avec des
valeurs républicaines laïcité diversité
solidarité le socle républicain des
radicaux de gauche
l'interprétation elle ensuite est libre
peut-être le meilleur moyen d'exister au
sein du sénat
il arrive effectivement à exister
quelquefois faire bouger les lignes
la vraie difficulté à mon sens c'est de
fédérer sans doute pour ce groupe autour
je le redis d'un vrai noyau de père j'ai
quelques individualités qui à mon avis
leur pose quelques fois des difficultés
de lecture d'ensemble du groupe au sénat
les sénateurs prg font partie du groupe
rds le rassemblement démocratique social
et européen dont ils sont majoritaires
un groupe un peu à part ce groupe dans
le sénat c'est vraiment unique danger de
l'assemblée parlementaire il y en a pas
à l'assemblée nationale par exemple
pourquoi parce qu'il y a des gens entre
guillemets de droite est déjà entre
guillemets de gauche qui siègent
ensemble et qui prennent des décisions
ensemble
moi je trouve que c'est un groupe très
intéressant et très intelligent oui
justement quand on aime on ne compte pas
mais quand on n'aime pas on devrait en
tenir compte aussi la tirade pourrait
presque avoir valeur de slogans pour les
radicaux de gauche peser dans le débat
politique c'est tout l'enjeu pour un
parti parfois marginalisés je crois
et qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
travail effectivement de reconstruction
d'une image forte de ce qu'est le
radicalisme et on en a particulièrement
besoin et cette reconstruction passe pas
un les prochaines élections cantonales
le prg y joue une partie de sa survie
ici dans les couloirs du sénat
et bien au delà voilà patrick roger du
monde nous a rejoint bonsoir patrick
pour poursuivre donc ce nécessaire
exercice de clarification politique
monsieur ouellette ont fait tomber tous
les guillemets mais commençons par une
question simple vous disiez tout à
l'heure que vous étiez pour l'alternance
niveau de l'élection présidentielle vous
êtes également pour l'alternance en ce
qui concerne le sénat le président un
taux important dans l'organisation et
titien républicaine il est le numéro 2
il semblerait d'après les augures que
vous êtes souvent mais sur les
journalistes que la présence du sénat va
se jouer à quelques voix
naturellement les radicaux il voit grand
intérêt
je coupe du monde contient des vôtres je
considère que ce serait un événement
d'abord d'une certaine manière avec un
peu en phase historique que de voir le
scénar revenir à gauche il ne l'a pas
été depuis le dernier prix un radical
qui était gaston-monnerville c'est déjà
peut-être ainsi de ça d'ailleurs
ensuite parce que à moins d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle ce serait
formidable élan donné à la gauche une
formidable démonstration il faut donc
créer les conditions pour ce faire donc
vous militez pour une alliance avec une
parti socialiste pour ces élections
sénatoriales et le parti socialiste ne
vous fait pas de cadeau il y a trois
tours lors de cette élection
j'ai envie de dire contenu au premier
tour voire au second
ensuite nous verrons la possibilité ou
pas de nouer des alliances
c'est ainsi que vont les élections on
peut s'entendre dès le premier tour mais
je crois qu'il sera de meilleure méthode
si la gauche veut gagner la présence du
sénat d'avoir incarné à radical au
premier tour pourquoi parce que si nous
sommes
d'entrée de jeu en bloc à bloc comment
l'assemblée nationale
c'est pas dans les traditions de cette
maison et je pense qu'un certain nombre
de voix risquent de faire défaut
commerce il y en avait quatre radical il
peut rassembler largement depuis il est
normal que les radicaux qui sont bruno
senna et envie de se battre sous leurs
propres couleurs
alors soyons clair dans cette maison est
parfois assez subtil c'est complexe
vous dites vous faites vous laisser
placer planer la menace un certain
nombre de voix pourrait faire défaut
éventuellement aux candidats de gauche
ça c'est la menace subliminal nos miss
c'est un principe est ce que vous
pourriez vous entendre avec gérard
larcher éventuellement moi je n'ai rien
dit de tel et voudrait déjà être
troisième tôt avant que le premier ne
tenait lieu entendons les élections si
l'ump est majoritaire
gérard larcher sera réélu si les
socialistes sont majoritaires tout seuls
ils ne viendront même pas cherché les
radicaux vous le savez bien
si nous sommes dans une situation rêvée
pour nous un vienne - un train chez que
cela eh bien nous verrons ce qu'il ya
lieu de faire ce qui compte c'est de
conquérir la présidence du sénat c'est
comme si vous a déjà fait des
propositions
non non mais gérard larcher de nombreux
spectacles il est un bon président du
sénat à paris n'est pas l'amour comme
politique il est donc normal que
que je le combats taha à ce moment là
non mais nous verrons le moment venu qui
le mieux placé à gauche pour devenir
prêtre du sénat comment vivez-vous les
nominations qui ont pu être effectués
ces derniers temps je pense notamment à
celle du président du groupe union
centriste nicolas about qui a été nommé
par gérard larcher au conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel que d'autres et
quelques autres comment comment vous
vivez ça comme la preuve avant l'heure
que la présence du sida ne va se jouer à
quelques voix donc connaissait déjà de
l'est grappillé voyez que vous venez
nous avons des avances à skanda ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure et que donc les
choses seront difficiles et qu'il faut
se donner tous les moyens pour y arriver
tous les moyens pour y arriver
c'est un rôle essentiel pour les
radicaux lors de ce combat pour la
présidence il n'y a également un autre
groupe charnière c'est l'union centriste
qui regroupe des sensibilités un petit
peu différente des gens du modem des
gens du nouveau centre des gens de
l'alliance centriste de jean arthuis
ils viennent d'élire un nouveau
président françois zocchetto c'est
plutôt proche de jean arthuis donc
et est ce que ça vous ouvre des
perspectives de rapprochement est ce
qu'une éventuelle fédération fusion de
ces deux ces groupes que vous perdez
c'est qu'elle peut exprimer là dessus
vous disiez que le sénat est une maison
particulière spécifiques
n'allons pas trop loin dans les rêves
quand même voilà mais dans le sujet nous
venons de voir disait que notre groupe
est très particulier parce qu'il ya des
gens d'un côté des gens de l'autre
lorsque je regarde le groupe nous
ressemble je vois aussi qu'il y a des
gens qui vont régulièrement à l'ump et
des gens qui votent régulièrement et
l'opposition donc il y a là un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont aussi
différents je mets le doigt là dessus
parce que j'avais l'impression quand à
certains opposants après cette
présentation de ce groupe qu'on nous
faisait passer pour un groupe un peu
passéistes nous sommes dans l'actualité
nous sommes des laïcs respectueux
d'autrui
nous votons en notre âme et conscience
il nous est arrivé de voter des textes
du gouvernement et non des moindres
puisque la réforme la constitution est
passé grâce à nous il nous est arrivé
lorsque nous étions dans la majorité
noire était pas du tout si c'était à
refaire je referais tout de suite
et d'ailleurs quand je vois quand même
l'oxygène que ça donnait quant au débat
parlementaire je pense que c'est ce qui
ne l'a pas fait qu'ils doivent le
regretter mais vous savez que ceux qui
ne l'ont pas fait en particulier
socialistes ne l'ont pas fait pour des
raisons plus idéologique et d'unité de
parti que pour des raisons de danalyse
réellement de ce texte qui était un mode
ex me nous est arrivé aussi
je n'ai pas perdu mon fils de voter
contre les textes que nous étions la
majorité lors du dernier gouvernement de
lionel jospin par exemple nous sommes la
gauche de la raison et nous essayons de
juger à notre âme et conscience nous
sommes pas des purs doctrinaire
maintenant nous savons nous habitons
tous nos enfants c'est la gauche
d'accord voilà qui est dit vous avez
rappelé votre attachement à la laïcité
aujourd'hui les députés avant les
sénateurs débattent de la révision des
lois éthiques il y à un statu quo
manifestement sur les principales
mesures et on évoque le retour des
valeurs de la droite catholique défendu
par un groupe actif de députés de l'ump
qui menacent ambitionnerait l'assemblée
nationale des députés qui ont d'ailleurs
signé une pétition un texte sur
notamment la recherche sur les embryons
dans la croix et comment est ce que vous
vous préparez à ce débat ici j'ai même
vu les propos du pack du pape et des
évêques sur ces sujets là moi je ne suis
pas un spécialiste la bioéthique mais je
les dis je suis un homme de réseau et
vous l'avez rappelé la réussite est
consubstantiel du radicalisme
à partir de là au nom de la raison je
considère qu'il faut aller vers le
progrès et qu'il faut s'adapter à notre
époque dont les textes qui sont en
préparation sur la recherche sur les
embryons
j'ai vu maintenant qu'on vous mêmes des
bébés laboratoire ans c'est ainsi qu'il
a été dénommée tout et même sur
l'appellation le terril eux mêmes
choisie mais c'est important
le bébé au boutte rappelons le par ce
nom par son prénom
vous quel est votre sentiment c'est très
bien il va contribuer à sauver un de ses
frères on ne peut que s'en réjouir
tout de même il faut être sacrément
obscurantistes pour dire que ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle mais vous savez
ceux là même qui s'oppose à ce texte
s'oppose pour certains d'entre eux à
l'avortement est presque à l'utilisation
du préservatif donc c'est le passé ça il
faut pas y faire attention
maintenant il faut que tout soit et la
france est plutôt bien placé la matière
que tout cela soit bien cadré bien
surveillé et encadrée par des textes
l'initiative sérieux et précis 6 à cela
que nous travaillons et que nous avons
travaillé avant déjà je trouve que la
france mais est ce qu'on peut vous
demander une appréciation générale sur
le projet de de loi bioéthique dont qui
actuellement est en discussion à
l'assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
finalement le texte qui qui va sortir la
des débats est trop frileux ou est-ce
que vous portez alors on va voir comment
il va sortir et puis ensuite il va venir
ici et le sénat souligné hier dans un de
vos papiers amélioré beaucoup les textes
par les temps qui courent donc il jouera
encore son rôle mais quand à la
bioéthique les radicaux on est elle
encore des précurseurs comme pour les
primaires même si ce n'est pas la même
chose bien sûr puisque bernard charles à
l'époque lorsqu'il était député du lot a
été un des premiers à porter des voies
dures et hic est que dominique orliac
notre député du lot actuelle continue à
travailler très fortement là dessus nous
sommes des femmes et des hommes éclairés
et nous soutenons le progrès mais nous
sommes vigilants on en défendant notre
essai au nom de la raison républicain
donc avec jean louis borloo j'y reviens
est ce que vous pourriez me définir non
mais j'ai employé cette expression
républicains comme cela vous me dites
vous revenez là dessus subitement et je
ne vais donc vous répéter ce que je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure il faut que le
parti de jean louis borloo lui-même se
définissait ce qu'il reste à l'ump
auquel cas pour toutes les raisons que
j'ai dit quand on au positionnement et à
nos frais pour l'avenir c'est pas
possible
où ils sortent de l'ump est on